our next two guests are two culinary
titans icons and just
i'm fangirling out one is a personal
idol of mine the founder of momofuco
restaurant group who just changed the
entire game and industry and the other
is an incredible author and food
reporter for the new york times i also
love her cookbook called indian-ish it's
one of my favorites and i'm so excited
that she's here together they just
released a new cookbook titled cooking
at home or how i learned to stop
worrying about recipes and love my
microwave please welcome david chang and
priya krishna
[Applause]
david i've been looking through your
cookbook
it is once again something i haven't
seen how did you guys come up with this
idea and what was the origin story for
you
well we've known each other a long time
and over the years we've found out that
our moms cook very similar which is
no no recipes have you ever given your
recipe mom has never given me a recipe
she has never followed a recipe she will
never follow a recipe so when dave
approached me about writing this
cookbook he was like i don't think we
should include recipes
this is what i'm talking about this
outside of the box thinking of let's
make a cookbook that doesn't have
recipes
so of course i immediately opened it and
started like shoveling shuffling through
the pages and i'm so excited because
today you're going to show us how it
works it's just actually how most people
i think cook is just intuitively most
great the best cooks you know are the
best cooks you know
not because they follow recipes to a tea
right because they get creative right
take us through this recipe teach me
teach me teach me we're just going to
mix our peppercorns together because we
only have one microwave bowl so
do you want to explain why we are doing
this yeah so cachoei pepe simple dish
cheese pepper pasta deceptively
difficult to make you know you had it
hard to create that emulsification that
silky sauce you get cheese stuck on the
bottom of the pot dave was like what if
we made
cache pepe like you make a box of
macaroni and cheese i'm so excited to
make this dish more attainable
part of this is
you know
you have an idea of how you want it to
taste and then you think about what
steps you might be able to cut
or make quick more quickly and again
this isn't how i would make it in a
professional kitchen but now i now know
what it's like to be a parent and you
have to get dinner on the table you
might have five minutes ten minutes and
now with so many people staying at home
you're like i got a zoom call i gotta do
this
this is actually perfect for cooking at
home because the goal is to make
something delicious and how you get
there at home doesn't really matter
right and a classic favorite who doesn't
love caught chewy pepe it's one of my
favorite dishes on planet earth so it
starts with a microwave you microwave
peppercorns in olive oil this is a
really cool trick because in indian
cuisine there's like tempering where you
infuse the oil with the spices this is
basically doing that but in a shortcut
method like you're infusing the oil with
the peppercorns also bringing out the
flavor of the peppercorns and then we're
literally just making a sauce in the
blender
so drew you can literally like put the
cheese in put the water in like it's
just this is a dumpling so so imagine we
we've already cooked the pasta off or
this is a beautiful thing the pasta is
cooking right you take some of the pasta
water out and then you add some of the
pasta water to this
right inside yep right inside it's
taking a lot of professional concepts
and making it more applicable for home
so you're really tempering the cheese
so it doesn't melt
and stick to the pot um and then would
you prefer puree or liquid do you think
it's your favorite right
and then you just hold it down the whole
time kind of hard
[Applause]
so
this is this is easy now you would drain
your pasta right you're done
now all you're doing is you can do this
in a bowl or you can
bring it back to the pot and then fold
it in and
you can get the consistency you want but
again like home cooking to me in a
professional kitchen is about you better
hit the bullseye
at home you just want to hit the target
right that's how i love that analogy
so and so now you so we're literally
just oh my god putting the sauce on and
just tossing it
like this is just such an easier more
practical way to cook i'm just going to
take a bite here i'm going to buy a bite
that's
you know what's so infuriating when
people are like here's your pasta and
you're like
i
like a bigger portion i'm sorry i don't
i now you've made me have to call that
out loves big portions and i'll just eat
from the bowl okay perfect
oh my god
oh my god
um
[Applause]
the thing is
a lot of times at home people might feel
like they're um
not able to make a recipe because they
don't have the exact ingredients it
could be a different kind of cheese it
could be a different kind of pasta that
shouldn't prevent you from making
something delicious right
and the book is very much about like use
what you already have here's templates
for our strategies for making dinner
rather than prescriptive like add a
teaspoon of this a teaspoon of that like
we want cooking to work for the person
not for them to have to work for us you
know what i mean i love that that's such
a beautiful sentiment and very calming
and i'm so excited for you two geniuses
to show people that there is a different
avenue in which to go down for cooking
this is a revolution please go to our
website for the full recipe and david
and priya's beautiful amazing
imaginative incredible new book cooking
at home or how i learned to stop
worrying about recipes and love my
microwave thank you
[Music]